so they lied to us about the pandemic
and now it seems they're lying to us to
take us to war again this week we have
the appalling mark millie who of course
should have been fired in disgrace for
his lies and incompetence over
afghanistan let alone his ignorant woke
pandering hyping up russia's military
threat to ukraine and then biden the
great genius of foreign policy the adult
back in charge making a fool of himself
and america sadly with bellicose bluster
that the actual president of ukraine
told him was over the top and asked him
to stop according to the new york times
ukrainian officials expressed increasing
annoyance with the biden administration
and these are the people biden says he's
trying to help
meanwhile all those alliances biden
promised to restore completely fell
apart as the ukrainians and russians
decided to try and make progress
diplomatically by meeting with the
french and the germans and excluding
america
look i don't think it's just okay for
russia to invade another country the
russians invaded my family's country
hungary in 1956 to crush our revolution
america and the west did nothing and my
family had to suffer under communism for
another 30 odd years but this is my
country now america
and what i want to know is why our
leaders aren't focused on the threats to
our country with anything like the
energy and passion they seem to have for
threats to ukraine the establishment
seems obsessed with fighting russia it's
russia russia russia all over again just
listen to the pompous grandstanding from
all the senators both parties out on the
sunday shows this morning talking about
a bill that they want to pass this
coming week
i want sanctions on putin's behavior now
sanction sanctions sanctions sanctions
serious sanctions massive sanctions an
array of pre-invasion sanctions
sanctioning these are sanctions beyond
any that we have ever levied before
consequences will be devastating
crippling to their economy crippling the
crippling effect mother of all sanctions
so they want the mother of all sanctions
right now to try and stop russia
attacking another country great good for
them but where are the sanctions against
china which has been attacking our
country for years
the kinds of things these senators were
citing as grounds for the mother of all
sanctions were russia's cyber attacks on
ukraine russia destabilizing ukraine's
economy well that sure sounds familiar
china has been launching cyber attacks
on us for years remember the theft of
millions of records from the federal
government's office of personnel
management they stole the information of
quote everybody who has worked for tried
to work for or works for the united
states government
china has been destabilizing our economy
for decades destroying our working class
stealing our intellectual property they
force u.s companies operating china like
disney to have communist party cells
these establishment boobies say we need
urgent sanctions on russia because of
military maneuvers that look hostile
where are the urgent sanctions to stop
china's military maneuvers that actually
are hostile
planning to invade taiwan controlling
the south china sea new ships new
missiles people talk about russia and
its sphere of influence how would we
feel if our enemies were in our own
backyard when is our feckless
establishment going to wake up china is
already in our backyard aggressively
expanding its influence in south and
central america in the caribbean
building roads in jamaica telecoms and
belize giving computers to school kids
in the dominican republic infrastructure
in venezuela a deep space listening
station in argentina you think this is
because china wants to really help those
countries
these are hostile moves against america
and then what about all the americans
the chinese regime has killed
through the pandemic of course which
leaked from their lab and they could
have stopped but didn't they poured
drugs into our country there were 75 000
opioid overdoses in america last year
mostly due to fentanyl
of which china is the primary source
president xi is a brutal authoritarian
dictator he could stop all this but he
chooses not to because he is attacking
us
so where are the mother of all sanctions
in response to china's attacks on our
country
nowhere because our establishment is in
bed with china some of them literally
they bought off the biden family with
cash and lucrative deals
they forged business ties with senator
dianne feinstein's husband as she
defended the chinese communist party's
public image it's not just democrats of
course elaine chao former transportation
secretary and wife of mitch mcconnell
she was accused of abusing her office to
help her family company with their china
dealings they work our systems china
exploits our broken lobbying industry to
shape policy in their interests
they infiltrate our universities steal
our intellectual property they buy
american farmland to gain power over our
food supply when are we going to get
serious about china when
our establishment is committing a slow
motion national suicide they get all
excited about sending troops to eastern
europe risking a new and pointless
military entanglement but they won't do
the hard work of unraveling and
reversing our deadly decades-long
entanglement with china it is madness
complete madness
i'm steve ducey i'm brian kilmeade and
i'm ainsley earhardt and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis